so what I want to do here is have a
discussion on the fighting style and
suit of black panther and what I'm
hoping is that at the end of all this
you'll walk away with a better
understanding of his mastery in
different forms of martial arts as well
as how the black panther suit makes the
trauma a technological equal to the Iron
Man armors within the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and the comics
the so is my colleagues because his
education both within and without
Wakanda was designed to make him highly
intelligent the life training of
T'Challa was also designed to make him
extremely capable in terms of its role
as a leader in fighting prowess and
hand-to-hand combat
to this end Black Panther is a master of
multiple forms of martial arts both
major and minor including karate
Taekwondo judo brazilian jujitsu Krav
Maga and Muay Thai however as we get
into this I actually want to take a
second to move away from the comics and
have a bit of a discussion on some of
the deadlier forms of martial arts
employed by Black Panther so beginning
with G kundo this style was created by
Bruce Lee in 1967 as a hybrid of Chinese
kung fu and winged tune under the belief
that the existing styles of traditional
martial arts were too rigid and were
unable to effectively cope with more
exotic fighting styles that hailed from
other parts of the world in addition to
this the varying forms of martial arts
predating jeet kune do-- wasted energy
in the eyes of Bruce Lee who believed
that this energy could be put to better
use by more efficiently disabling a
target and ending the conflict to this
end ji kunda was developed under Bruce
Lee's mantra to be like water and that
the style emphasized simple movements
with high impact while allowing the
style to adapt to movements of others
regardless of their fighting styles
moving on to capoeira
this style originated in the early 19th
century following the incorporation of
West African slaves within the nation of
Brazil while this time period saw slaves
coping with their bondage and taking up
residence in small territories referred
to as Columbus capoeira arose as a style
of fighting
disguised as a dance allowing its
students and teachers to engage in the
training process using drums and music
leaving most authorities unaware of its
practice to this end Cavalier emphasizes
an uninterrupted flow of movements
focused on chaining hits together while
battling multiple opponents at once with
special emphasis on adaptation and quick
thinking transitioning to Brazilian
jiu-jitsu this style was based off the
traditional jiu-jitsu from Japan which
was brought to Brazil by Gio amore while
the early style of fighting was almost
identical to Japanese traditions in the
early 1900s the Gracie family began to
blend the traditional methods of you
Jitsu with existing styles of Judo and
martial arts from Brazil using this as a
family recipe so to speak Brazilian
Jujitsu roasts
prominence after Royce Gracie used the
Gracie family style of Brazilian Jujitsu
to win the first second and fourth USC
championships coming out of the
recognition that styles of fighting like
Taekwondo kung-fu and others found
success by utilizing the length of arms
and legs Brazilian jiu-jitsu eliminates
this issue by emphasizing ground style
fighting forcing the opponent to use
their bodies instead of her arms and
legs jumping to muy Thai unlike other
styles listed here this form hails from
Thailand and treats the overall body as
a complete weapon composed of different
parts in traditional methods of
instruction the hands become the sword
and dagger the shins become the armor
for blocking the elbows act in his maces
and the knees and legs became the action
staff using this belief system muy Thai
acts as a fighting art of attrition and
that the opponent is quite literally
pummeled with a barrage of attacks until
they can no longer stand the brutal
assault and either give up or are beaten
to submission
finally the deadliest form of martial
art and the arsenal of black panther
comes in the form of Krav Maga largely
considered to be the most dangerous
style of fighting in the world designed
by legendary fighter Amir lichtenfeld
Krav Maga is largely used by the Israeli
Defense Force or IDF and incorporates
elements of Aikido judo boxing and
wrestling but unlike others on this list
Krav Maga is not a combat sport meaning
that those practising this style are not
trained to concern themselves with the
well-being of their opponents instead
this style of fighting uses a barrage of
attacks and Isana maneuvers but with the
intention of ending in the opponent's
death now having said all that like any
great fighter Black Panthers first and
foremost stability is as mine while
model remains ambiguous about the
teenage years of T'Challa outside of his
experiences in romance with storm what
we do know through the publication's of
his adult life is that by way of his
extensive training starting a childhood
his body and reflexes have been trained
to those a peak human ability and that
using his exceptional mind and combining
it with his training and enhanced
abilities from the Panther God T'Challa
was able to defeat some of Marvel's most
capable fighters including Captain
America daredevil and wool rain while
model does not go into exact detail on
what discipline - charlie uses in
addition to the forms listed above the
brunt of his fighting style appears to
hail from African based martial arts
like dombay Angola and a lieutenant
tradition al a wrestling form a rigid
in Africa because these martial arts
forms aren't encountered by very many
fighters the styles presented here along
with the likelihood that the royal
family of Wakanda had created a martial
arts form of its own as well as T'Challa
being a world-class gymnast in parkour
artists without parallel make him one of
the most capable hand-to-hand fighters
on the planet with the exception of
taskmaster
now jamming through his suit and
technologies the Black Panther uniform
takes advantage of the numerous
properties of vibranium and gifts
T'Challa
a definitive edge in combat as well as
various gadgets and enhancements that
rival those created by Tony Stark's Iron
Man armors within Marvel Comics while
the black panther suit has a vibrating a
chainmail micro weave that lends the
user immunity to piercing weapons energy
and ballistic attacks including Starks
repulsor rays and psionic attack
shontella past this was not established
until volume 3 up until this point the
Black Panther suit was actually just
black spandex that symbolized the
Panther tribe
however because wider crystal freeze had
believed that the chala failed to stand
alongside Marlo's top tier heroes due to
both storytelling and character design
he initiated a series of sweeping
changes including the addition of
vibranium as part of the challahs outfit
as well as it suits ability to cloak and
mimic the appearance of whatever look to
child desires as a result the vibranium
within the black panther suit acts as an
absorber of kinetic energy meaning that
when hit by bullets for example the
momentum of the bullets is stopped
entirely
when the suit absorbs their kinetic
energy what this means is that when a
bullet is fired instead of the
projectile hitting the suit and the
kinetic energy carrying it away by
bouncing off instead the energy is
absorbed meaning the bullets literally
just fall to the ground
now although Captain America's shield
and black panther suit are both made of
vibranium in the comics there are
differences between the two
referencing my video on Captain America
shield the vibranium contained within is
a little more durable than two challahs
owing to the fact that Captain America's
shield is a combination of vibranium
proper in a prototype form of adamantium
to this end because the shield is a
solid chunk of metal it stands in
contrast to Black Panther suit and that
because it's a mesh micro weave the suit
is vulnerable to attack from characters
like an man who can squeeze between the
fibers but also means the Black Panther
can be forcefully removed from the suit
finally regarding the boots and claws
aspects of the uniform contain their own
special attributes which contribute to
the overall capabilities of black
panther the tips of the claws utilize
vibranium of antarctic origin which
differentiates itself from the wakandan
variety by containing an anti metal
property what this means is that in the
instance of Avengers 3 volumes 22 to 23
during the battle with Ultron and Arctic
vibranium breaks down all metals at the
molecular levels including Ultron's
adamantium body regardless of their
design or capabilities conversely the
boots of the Black Panther suit have
energy dampening qualities allowing to
chala to fall from incredible Heights
and land without harm and without making
any real noise now while these
attributes all exist in the comics in
the film Captain America Civil War all
these elements were carried over and
expanded allowing to chala the same
dampening quality found in the comics as
well as running and enhanced feeds a
feature which would normally have been
provided by the Panther God vast with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end and let me know if
you guys are interested in learning more
about the principles of vibranium and
how its introduction into the world
outside of Wakanda eventually led to the
formation of adamantium and I will catch
you guys later please